gentlemen it's time it's time for the
next Tick Tock Wars and I'm gonna be
pitting Dr Mike against Stephen he
[Music]
emotional damage that thing hurt my ears
so bad can I sue you for that Stephen
how confident are you in your Tick Tock
abilities oof I I'm not a tick tocker
but I'll give it up you're a bigger tick
tocker than I am a tick tocker
both of you will have 30 minutes to
create a tick tock our first challenge
is he whoop and emotional damage words
that have stayed in this first Tick Tock
invent a new catchphrase 30 minutes go
wait it starts now 30 minutes no
where should I go I kind of want to do
something where it's like people damage
oh I got it I got it
I think I'm feeling something it's about
every Asian parent's solution to every
illness
where do I get a great place ah from
Asian Dad got upgrade today it's a rule
of Threes you always need a third Dr
Mike is gonna love the medical accuracy
of this okay I need to borrow your hand
just just hold this chat my girlfriend
to stop me
yes I don't know how to edit things on
my phone I'm sorry
oh my God alrighty so I have one from
each of you which should I watch first I
wonder what's yours okay all right all
right but where I got I got I got I
gotta God I gotta I gotta set it up all
right
here's your doctor
doing things for you here's your doctor
doing things for you for you
sad patient
not you're listening
patient wishes for tissues
of the doctor
okay partying or taking shots
doctors got to come in cheers
[Music]
I actually made that sound with your
mouth
let me do it for you
I just realized that could not be your
foot wow so the doctor got the tissues
to be emotionally supportive Spilled Out
the shot to prevent alcoholism and the
doctor checked the reflexes and also
allowed playtime with a dog which are
all healthy things so my new catchphrase
is let me
let me okay really impressive and as we
all know one of the golden rules of
Comedy is it's always funnier when you
have to explain it let's move on to
Stevens hey Dad um
I woke up with a sore throat it feels
like I do I don't know oh okay so from
all of the medical expertise I've ever
studied passed down to tradition I have
just a cure for you
fat I I just uh I fell off the bike and
I sprained my elbow and it's like
probably probably bleeding people uh I
only gotta be in geography people rub my
girlfriend just um just stopped me
PayPal Rob breaking news this is cnbs
here with the breaking news of a viral
takeout Trend that is apparently
revolutionized the entire medical
industry worth one saying
[Music]
all righty well I'll say this Mike
really impressed me he made a very funny
Tick Tock he did a bunch of different
shots technically it was very impressive
and because of that I'm gonna give that
um two-thirds a cup of bear drool okay
that's two-thirds of a cup that's a lot
of the drools Stephen uh it was very
tight it was very Punchy the premise was
very very clear I think I'm gonna give
Stephen a full cup of bear drool because
he invented a new catchphrase Mike was
taking inspiration from something that
exists Steven invented Vapor Rub I can
see this training I can see VapoRub
becoming new that's trademark that's
gonna be
which means Steven is going above and
beyond to create a built-in brand deal
for himself I'm going to give one point
over to Steve oh my God thank you so
much Sam
goop products and miracle cures things
that should be banned in this next Tick
Tock show us a doctor that's off brand
hello bear bear please help me
you're about to see my very first doctor
character of my entire Channel
[Music]
we're gonna watch Steven's first okay
off-brand doctors off brand doctors
um what kind of hospital is this it
doesn't really look like a real house oh
no no everything is is totally cool I
got my degree from wish okay um yeah I'm
just having a sore throat no problem uh
have you tried some sneeze candy
you mean cough drop or you could drink
some bazooka honey you mean Manuka honey
my dad told me this one you could put
some lime paste under your nose Tiger
Bomb what kind of place what are you
gonna put me in an MRI scan next we do
have an IRS scan okay I must have gone
to the wrong place I thought this was
the Mayo Clinic oh no this is the
ketchup Clinic
is that a reference to something like
have you heard of Dr Oz or it's such a
cold day but I gotta go check out my
heart man this is not good oh what is it
what what what is this
shouldn't this say cardiologist
and what is as seen on TV
hey how you doing welcome welcome to the
office this is where we produce our I
mean treat patients you know we got to
make sure everyone's healthy with the
heart this is this is the body this is
this is the body you see this is why am
I sitting without my shirt on this is
awkward who's the doctor here who's had
10 seasons of a successful show
all right I'm already seeing some
dysfunctions yeah I'm pretty sure those
are uh binoculars they're champ
pretty sure I'm the one that went to
medical school okay
this is your body
there's something wrong with your body
I'm gonna fix it you see that
I'm a surge I'm a surgeon and I know
just what you need really I mean you're
a heart surgeon though and what do you
think I need you may not have voted for
me
but this is what you need
BS
Miracle piece why would I want this you
watch your mouth you
young man
that's the finest cow bull excrement
that will extend your life cause you to
lose weight make you be super human and
have superhuman potential did I check
that backtrack Factory back we don't
need fact check
so vote for me in 2022 Senate you don't
need fact checks in that hospital I'm
very pleased across the board here let's
start with Stephen heat what a clear
concept right very straightforward the
off-brand doctor we're doing a lot of
word play there wordplay is very fun so
because of that I'm going to give this a
very respectable two uh Roxy legs
which is almost as many now yes uh now
on the other hand we have Dr Mike and
and now this concept wasn't quite as
clear as Stevens was but I think that
actually worked to your advantage Mike
Mike went above and beyond here he went
to the next level I learned a little bit
something about myself
I'm gonna give it the highest possible
score you can get on the Roxy leg meter
do you know how high that is three legs
because she's only got three of them
it's only funny because she's okay yes
that's gonna be a point over there for
Dr Mike
one-to-one tied heading into the final
round all the marbles oh boy all the bee
whoops
to throne The Tick Tock Wars champion of
today you've longed for their acceptance
you've cried and begged so loud in this
final Tick Tock show us what would
finally make your father proud oh boy oh
boy 30 minutes
ghost
you can't even see the tie we're stuck
because currently I have two jokes I
have no escalation between them
foreign
[Music]
what will finally make your father happy
it's time for me to judge the final
round
[Music]
oh we have a guest judge Chris Chris
Collins is here the reigning champion of
tick tock Wars that's right you've held
for a year now oh it's time for you to
uh fourth guest judge
lay down
you're you're very slobbery okay what
will make their fathers happy I'm
excited to see
I just go to the medical school so so am
I going to the best school which one
oh you have a doctor might already be a
doctor when he was nine I just got a New
York Times article Mike just bought the
New York Times I just won a Nobel Prize
Mike has five I did my degree with the
scholarship scholarship so what that
means I didn't have to pay tuition
this is gonna be an uphill battle
Stephen's gonna lay down some emotional
damage on your buddy oh but we let's we
have we still have give me a chance like
my father wouldn't
kill emotion no damage
[Music]
Papa I just finished my first bath
I just beat up idubbbz
so
Papa I got a perfect MCAT score
and
I think the life using just compression
just compression yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I finally made the cure for cancer
giving it to you
we had like the same thought we had the
same progression but that's good you
guys didn't plan that like no we didn't
respect that that is that that was a
good question great minds think alike uh
Chris and I need to deliberate yeah so
YouTube could please step out this is
close
yeah this is really it is I was actually
not expecting mics to be as good as it
was because this is Steven's wheelhouse
and it was Flawless to be honest yes
Stephen was teed up he got the timing
right he got the pacing right so good
let's give Mike some credit here there's
music involved there was music he has
on-screen text in there yeah that's
worth something that would yep the fake
beard was disturbing but entertaining I
think I've made a decision okay
um I think we share the same opinion
okay scoring wise
um one person has received a three while
the other person has received a full
four out of four rounds with Chris Avila
which is technically me the winner of
tick-tock wars in the new reigning
Tick-Tock Champion is
Stephen he
yeah
oh sorry sir
I love you okay well check out our full
conversation where we talk everything
there is to know about Stephen he's life
before YouTube in the middle of YouTube
and what the future holds click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
yay
[Music]